die Wahl hier in Berlin in der
Hauptstadt durften nämlich nach neuesten
Recherchen auch Minderjährige abstimmen
obwohl sie gar nicht wahlberechtigt sind
wie die Kollegen der Welt berichten
wurden mehrere Jugendliche nicht nur
Wahlzettel für die Bundestagswahl
sondern auch für die Wahl zum
Abgeordnetenhaus und somit zum
Volksentscheid ausgehändigt und das ist
illegal die Teenager hätten nur bei der
Wahl der
bezirkshirtsverordnetenversammlung
abstimmen dürfen dafür muss man
mindestens 16 Jahre alt sein für alle
anderen waren sind Bürger erst ab 18
Jahren logischerweise wahlberechtigt
nach all dem Chaos das ist schon gab
muss man sagen diese Wahl muss
eigentlich jetzt endgültig wiederholt
werden es zeigt sich der Saustall Berlin
all das was hier passiert hat nichts mit
Deutschland sonst zu tun wo
Gründlichkeit herrscht wo Dinge
passieren wie sie passieren sollen und
es geht ja nicht nur um Minderjährige
offenbar sondern es gibt auch Berichte
darüber dass nicht EU-Ausländer
abstimmen durften das ist auch da
Probleme gegeben hat bei der
bei der bei den verschiedenen Wahlen und
man muss sagen mich erinnert dass so ein
bisschen an meine Reporter Zeit in der
Auszug reine 2014 als ich über ein
Referendum berichtet habe und da habe
ich jemanden begleitet der einfach
zehnmal immer pro Russland abstimmen
konnte damals wurden diese Abstimmung
natürlich nicht kontrolliert das waren
Separatisten die damals in diesem Gebiet
waren und das was hier in Berlin
passiert das hat mich daran erinnert
also ich finde es absolut skandalös das
nicht mal über Konsequenzen gesprochen
wird wir nehmen das einfach alle so hin
ja gab ein paar Stimmen die haben nicht
gezählt dann haben Minderjährige
abgestimmt vielleicht nicht EU-Ausländer
und keiner redet darüber was das
eigentlich für Konsequenzen haben müsste
ja ich finde natürlich müsste es
zumindest eine Untersuchung geben und
danach die Feststellung ob es
schwerwiegende Verstöße gab und ob dann
eine Wahl wiederholt werden muss wann
hat das ganze auch mit dem Chaos es gab
keine Stimmzettel mehr und dann gab es
ja den Berlin-Marathon das heißt es kam
auch nichts mehr nach also ich meine das
muss man doch irgendwie einkalkulieren
alleine das nicht genügend Stimmzettel
gedruckt werden konnten gedruckt wurden
in Berlin in der Hauptstadt Deutschlands
ist eine dermaßende Bankrott Erklärung
für alle die zuständig waren hier für
diese Wahl wir wissen ja dass es
Rücktritte gab aber das alleine kann ja
noch nicht alles gewesen sein also wenn
es dort schwerwiegenden Verstöße gab
also ich meine wir schicken häufig genug
Wahlbeobachter in Länder wo wir ja davon
ausgehen dass es Regularien nicht
eingehalten werden in Entwicklungsländer
in Länder wo Diktatoren regieren und
dann sagen wir und zeigen mit dem Finger
die Wahl muss wiederholt werden das ist
das ist unverständlich also ich glaube
wir haben ja auch einen Ruf zu verlieren
mit solchen wahnsinnigkeiten die dann
Berlin passieren aber ist das Zufall
dass es ausgerechnet immer Berlin trifft
also es ist absoluter Zufall ich habe ja
gerade schon vom Saustall Berlin
getroffen es ist natürlich kein Zufall
dass es immer wieder hier passiert in
diesem Jahr von Rot-Rot-Grün regierter
statt wo nur Chaos herrscht wo nichts
funktioniert wo wir alle wissen wie es
ist wenn man aus Bürgeramt geht wo
nichts geordnet ist wo einfach alles
alles chaotisch ist und deswegen ist es
kein Zufall dass diese ja Organisatoren
dann nicht mal genügend Wahlzettel
gedruckt haben das nicht genügend
Kontrollen offenbar gab und das
minderjährige und nicht der EU-Ausländer
offenbar abstimmen konnten Paul wir
schauen nach vorne ich blick mal hier
nach rechts gerade um zu sehen wie die
Situation in Schöneberg Berlin
Schöneberg gerade ist in der Nähe des
Gasometers finden ja die Gespräche statt
und das sollte ja eigentlich nur mal so
ein vorsichtiges Abtasten werden ist da
vielleicht doch was drin mit Jamaika
gibt es vielleicht also doch noch eine
Chance für haben in Laschet wenn grüne
und Union sich da näher kommen und
mitten hinein in dieses Abtasten platzt
der Ärger und die Wut über das was
gelegt wurde und über das was wir
berichten konnten ja man muss es
mittlerweile wahrscheinlich die
handy-alarm Bombe für Jamaika nennen was
dort passiert ist deutlicher Polit
Thriller der sich da seit gestern Abend
ereignet hat vielleicht müssen wir noch
mal zusammenfassen für unsere Zuschauer
also gestern Nachmittag konnten wir bei
Bild exklusiv einzelne Inhalte aus dem
Gesprächen vermelden was die FDP-Führung
an die Union sich gewandt hat wie sie
sich an die Union gewandt hat da ging es
vor allem darum ob die CDU steht ob sie
wirklich
sondierungsfähig ist ob sie bereit ist
für dieses Bündnis gleichzeitig konnten
wir berichten dass Christian Lindner
dort sehr viel über Wirtschaft und
Finanzpolitik gesprochen hat wir konnten
außerdem aus den Vorgesprächen berichten
was dort bei der Union diskutiert wurde
die Inhalte selbst sind kein große keine
große Überraschung also das FDP und
Union sich eigentlich bei der Frage was
Jamaika angeht inhaltlich näher liegen
das war klar auch die Tatsache dass aus
der Union der Hinweis kam an die aus der
FDP der Hinweis an die Union kam ihr
müsst die Grünen rüberziehen auch das
keine große Überraschung ich dann so
aufgeregt weil das von denjenigen die es
so wollen so interpretiert wird dass
allein die Tatsache dass einzelne Sätze
rauskommen das Chaos der Union zeichnet
das ist das symbolisiert und ich habe so
ein bisschen das Gefühl FDP und
insbesondere grüne versuchen das jetzt
massiv zu instrumentalisieren für diese
Gespräche ich glaube sie wollten am Ende
ohnehin nicht mehr diese jamaika-option
weil sie sehen dass ich Armin Laschet
ans Amt klammert sozusagen oder als
Kanzlerkandidat den Anspruch weiter
untermauert weil sie sehen dass es Chaos
in der Partei gibt aber sie brauchen
jetzt sozusagen diese Klippe über diese
springen können man muss natürlich dann
zu sagen es gab vorher Gespräche mit der
SPD sowohl seitens der der grünen als
auch der FTP dann haben wir die
Vorgespräche gesehen von Grünen und FDP
mit dem berühmten Vierer selfie die
Rockband und die waren alle sehr schmale
peter ist in der Tat nichts
herausgetrunken außer was zu essen gab
und das war schon die sensationelle
Nachricht also es ist Vertraulichkeit
vereinbart worden um eben Vertrauen
aufzubauen sicherlich auch ein Test kann
man miteinander umgehen obwohl man ja
politisch durchaus auseinander liegt so
das hat funktioniert bei diesen dreien
und dann gibt es das erste Gespräch mit
der CDU und zack wird durchgestochen das
ist richtig so war es tatsächlich bei
den anderen ist wenig rausbekommen auch
da gab es einige einige leaks muss man
sagen insbesondere was Finanz und
Wirtschaftspolitik anging also zwischen
SPD und FDP aber natürlich ist bei der
Union momentan mehr Alarm und natürlich
spielen da verschiedene Kräfte eine
Rolle allerdings haben in allen Parteien
Politiker Interessen es gibt bei der FDP
solche die eine Ampel wollen andere die
Jamaika wollen es gibt das gleiche bei
den Grünen also da ist es nicht so
einfach zu sagen wer ist jetzt derjenige
der wen auch immer mit Informationen
versorgt das muss man tatsächlich offen
halten denn es gibt ganz ganz viele
Interessen und Politik ist da
tatsächlich in diesen Tagen ein Krimi da
kommt es auf Kleinigkeiten an auf jeden
Satz auf Vertraulichkeit auf das was
dann am Ende rauskommt und wenn wir
jetzt sehen dass die Süddeutsche Zeitung
zum Beispiel momentan titelt dass die
Sondierungen tatsächlich daran scheitern
könnten an dem was wir gestern berichtet
haben an der Tatsache dass überhaupt
etwas rausgekommen ist und sie
interpretiert es auch so die Süddeutsche
Zeit und sie interpretiert ist so das
ist der FDP gelegen sein
gelegen kommt
zwischen Union und FDP brennt es
lichterloh nach der Berichterstattung
hier bei Bild absolut das ist der Titel
und das ist etwas wo man sagen muss
genau so interpretiere ich es auch dass
die FDP auch durch die Reaktion die sie
dann gezeigt haben also wir haben
berichtet am Nachmittag und wenige
Minuten später hat FDP Vize Johannes
Vogel bereits reagiert in einem Tweet
und hat der Union vorgeworfen nervt und
dann hat Christian Lindner so schnell
diesen Tweet retweetet das ist außer wie
eine tatsächlich muss man sagen eine ja
Aktion auch der FDP als Reaktion darauf
und das ist glaube ich etwas wo man auch
worauf man erkennen kann dass die FDP
zumindest momentan etwas sucht
unbegründen zu können dass sie Jamaika
nicht sondieren oder nicht in
Koalitionsverhandlungen reingeht und
zunächst die Ampel machen und was würde
das bedeuten Thomas es würde bedeuten
dass ist die letzten Tage von Armin
Laschet als CDU-Vorsitzender sein kann
[Musik]